it begins on a dark
[Music]
look at this
subject for today
[Music]
[Music]
nailed it eat your heart out cnn yeah
uh really glad to be with you we'd love
to get to uh we're gonna talk about the
dnc convention post uh post convention
bump and
there isn't one uh we're gonna be
talking about completely justifiable
officer shootings
officers shooting yes that's right i
think that's a legal term
uh and we'll have the quartering his
name is jeremy jeremy jeremy
i don't know i forget his last name but
he will be here to talk about leafy
being uh banned on youtube along with
them potentially i can't believe we're
talking about leafy
yeah you're talking about leafy today i
don't know it's a douchebag name but
it doesn't mean that his speech should
not be uh protected
as well um a half visionary policeman is
not here he is important because he has
a real job so audio wade is oddly in
third chair how are you i'm doing well
how are you i don't
care
tim from hr is in uh in charge of audio
and then gerald a
is back yes a lot of people thought you
were dead i i
despite the reports i am not fired or
dead i know there's always a conspiracy
when you're
i'm like and even though it's like what
happened to the the white guy with the
blonde hair
you know tall the aryan dude where
where's that guy yeah
i'm glad he's gone yeah no not here uh
but you had uh your uh
your your testicles were working
overtime because you had a baby well
nine months ago they were yes yeah so
late for the game on that one but yeah
and then you pretty much take it out
i take a recess from that particular
activity yeah yeah
yeah otherwise and what's the name of a
little uh gerald a little luke
little luke and do you think he looks do
you think he looks more like you're more
like the mystery uh in some ways he
looks a lot like me and otherwise her so
we've heard from both like nurses would
say both
so usually and i actually think he looks
he looks a lot more like you than the mo
i think we have a picture too
adorable little baby uh yeah i think he
looks at him
yeah the glasses receding hairline that
early
jeez i see it both ways i don't know i
mean it's hard to i see it as a lazy
photoshop
i see whoever was working had already
clocked out like
gerald uh for nine months and my
question of the day to everyone out
there is
have you noticed that the goal posts and
we're going to be getting into a couple
of police shootings notice the goal
posts have moved now
completely uh as far as it used to be
unarmed black men to now it's just
a black man with a weapon that's
slightly less effective than the police
officers
right and when do you think it's
appropriate for a police officer to
shoot do you think that they should only
be able to use lethal force if you are
completely unarmed um i don't think most
americans
but you know what i'm i've been known to
be out of touch with that a little bit
right now
to change my mind is our rude awakening
uh also please do subscribe to crowder
bits
uh and uh mug club livewithcrowd.com mug
club that's the only thing that allows
us to survive
that allows us to create the change for
mines and uh uh purchase uh bulletproof
uh
vests everything yeah yeah yeah we did
that vehicles
hopefully we'll we'll do the the
bulletproof cars so you need that elon
musk i'm looking at you
um before before we move on to some
stories
this is this is fun yeah biden is
one of three candidates to ever not
receive
a post-convention bounce let's bring up
this overlapping the only other ones
were mcgovern and carrie that's that's
rough so this is a bounce in what in
in the post convention convention bounce
i guess just as far as they're voting
you know the only reason to have a
convention is basically to get out there
and have
a you know a parade of your ideas
he didn't get out there no he didn't no
he stayed in his bomb
shelter uh which is not bulletproof
because that would be uh that would be a
byproduct of
white patriarchy at least he didn't do a
carry where he had a negative one
negative
one the more we hear about you the less
we like and i don't know it was that
could just be because it was the year
they introduced hd
[Applause]
you definitely don't want 1080p those
things are cavernous no
yes it's like cami diaz 4k
just ended her career
bring back now i don't want to give
anybody a false sense of hope okay get
out and vote and this is
you know and this is where i sometimes i
just wish i were i wish that i was a
democrat i could vote twice
so get out yeah you know it's my legacy
a little piece of me stays button that's
mine it's voted
um i don't want to give you a false
sense of hope but i am more confident
now i think that donald trump will win
uh why do i think do i think donald
trump will get a bump post convention i
do because
it has to be a message of optimism we've
talked about this i think they might
have been watching the stream a little
bit because
this wasn't the focus of the campaign
but then uh and i hate to say that
people like i started it i
found out about uh about uh pizzagate
you know it's like okay
um but i did talk about this the
democrats they need a message of
negativity right now the deck is stepped
against you the economy is collapsing
uh you can't do it yourself so you need
this transcendent political figure to
save you which is
joe biden who's been in government for
64 years 65th the charm
and then on the republican side it has
to be hey we did have the best economy
ever hey we haven't been in major
wars hey we actually have had the lowest
crime until of course the rioting you
call them protest tomato
riot burning down on walgreens um that
needs to be the message for republicans
people need to be optimistic for
republicans to win people need to be
pessimistic for democrats to win
and they need to be pessimistic and not
believe that they're in control of their
own destiny at all they have to believe
that things are really bad and the only
way it can be fixed
is joe biden which to me that's that is
a horrible yeah
it's gotta be really sad to be a
democrat yeah you gotta you gotta watch
against this horrible narrative and then
yes your savior
okay i wanna go quickly yeah yeah this
this lady looks like uh if kellyanne
conway were one of those little like
dinosaurs you get in the cereal packets
that you put in water little pills
this is after you put kellyanne conway
in water
leave it in too long it's bubbly yes if
you leave it too long it gets bubbly
back to the way it was i'm sure she's a
nice lady i get so pissed off about the
usps thing by the way anyway bite my
tongue why
that's because you weren't here for two
weeks because no no he was busy
i don't know i was watching this show
it's all about overtime
why couldn't you just be like one of
these guys about the officer shootings
and just you know take off
me off and we do have to get to the
justified uh police shootings oh yeah uh
is is that uh they conflate absentee
balling right mailing down
yeah because because i've been uh i've
been i have voted before by absentee
ballot because i've been trying to talk
about it yeah very different there's
identification
you have to request it first yes you
have to do a lot of things
my problem with this entire thing right
here is one that the usps does not need
a single cent
to be able to get this done two if every
person in america voted that would be 75
percent of the mail they process in
one day not every person in america is
going to vote they're not all registered
i have all these letters
for santa claus exactly so there's no
issue there and by the way
the the issue what they're saying like
oh he cut overtime that's the issue it's
unions pissed off that he cut over time
because they would have to complete the
mail
once they started he changed the whole
system to make it better and they're
pissed about it that's it that's all
that's going on right now
they're heroes they're not hero
on the front lines of the 40 successful
delivery rate
they're on the front lines of playing
kickball with my black rifle espresso
machine
there's 41 too much to ask for that's
them doing their best that's them doing
their i'm trying really hard
have been losing money for 13 years
straight billions
you've cost the taxpayers billions if
not trillions if you're just for
inflation i have absolutely no idea
uh i don't know what the future is
exactly and you can be taken out by
someone with a van and an amazon sticker
hey you know what maybe you're not one
you're not part of the bear necessity no
you're not yeah
no no you're not um all right no i agree
with you we should do more on the usps
thing uh and you know maybe later
i understand unfortunately donald trump
obviously i think that there's itself
serving here
but the usps um it needs some uh some
revamping it does and that's what
they're trying to do right now
that's what that's what the joyce or
whatever his name is dejoy is trying to
do
but it's racist and they're saying
anyway we'll talk about this another
time because i'm pissed about it okay
apparently i need a minute we should
change the name of the ledger oh
gerald of course you said we were going
to talk about it later i didn't say
we're going to talk about it later you
lie all right let's go to this right now
of course have been riots in kenosha
wisconsin and i want to warn you there
will be some graphic content today so
again the question of the day is when do
you think that police are justified in
using lethal force
does the perpetrator have to be aiming a
gun uh at the fed which i guess doesn't
matter because it happened in georgia
and people were like well he
but it was dark though so he probably
wouldn't have hit him in the face
probably not
yeah oh okay i guess let's just send out
cops let's just
let's just put cops against the wall in
front of a firing line like che guevara
let's how about we just do that at this
point yeah
if you don't want them to defend
themselves at all even when a gun
taser sorry is aimed at the face but in
this case we have
two uh actually uh situations that
occurred over the weekend i thought for
sure when i said the one over the
weekend of the guy with the knife i
thought
this isn't to go anywhere sure sure
enough protest it surprises me now
the the the standard bearer for protest
is very very low
yeah we literally we literally had over
everything
child abusers sex offenders who've been
arrested for assaulting officers
before assaulting officers now aiming
tasers at faces
and they still protest as an unjustified
shooting so you know um
i'm out of touch that's my white
privilege talking but let's get to the
first one here in kenosha wisconsin
some of these clips will be graphic this
is the reason
you've heard the story unarmed black men
shot by police that they are protesting
this is walking around from the
passenger side they've asked him to get
on the ground
yep and they're in the gun at him and
he's reaching reaching reaching reaching
[Applause]
wow i mean i don't know why you seem
surprised yeah
you know when police officers have you
on the other side of the car their
weapons are drawn and they're ordering
you to do something
that's usually a cue that you have posed
a threat well i should probably not do
anything else
bring up that still if we have it bring
up the still here this wasn't a guy who
was just walking away from officers look
at that tension
that guy is basically horizontal like
like the kid and what about bob when
richard dreyfuss is teaching him how to
dive
yeah yeah right exactly that's what he's
doing that's a guy
that's not a guy who is just passionate
like i was just getting my registration
uh officer i was trying to put it in
neutral because that could be a safety
hazard for your sorry white house
and clearly clearly there's context
because all of the officers already had
their guns out yeah before the guy was
walking around the car back
into his car so there's definitely going
into his car we have a statement from
the uh the
governor that jacob blake was shot
multiple times in broad daylight
what is that first off multiple times
doesn't matter
broad daylight doesn't matter was the
guy posing a threat
was the guy not complying could the guy
have turned around and shot officers
doesn't matter if he shot him i don't
care if it's dusk dawn
nautical twilight civil twilight it
could not be less relevant
yeah and again if you if all you need to
know is the colors of the people
involved
you're reasoning like a child yeah
you're actually you're not able to sort
out the morality and obviously there's
some kind of crazy
situation going on again we have to
reduce it down to the color of the
people involved the cop was white the
person was black
yeah i was just reaching in to put the
air conditioning on
recycle because otherwise it's not
efficient
yeah and then the governor basically
said here are all the other cases that i
know that have been tragic he
tries to lump all these things together
you know what he didn't say he didn't
say
one word in support of police officers
who felt that their life was in danger
and a man was trying to get into his car
to grab something he didn't say
one word to say let's wait for the facts
let's make sure we get everything lined
up first
these cops are trying well the other
thing is we actually do have some facts
let's bring up these facts here from uh
the county uh
man blake actually questioned his number
one trend on twitter right now what you
won't see is he had a warrant out for
his arrest he was a sex offender
and it already assaulted officers and
resisted arrest after pulling a gun
in a bar in 2015. model citizens my
guess is that probably
came up if they ran his plates or they
had him pulled aside because that right
away would show up when you run
someone's registration right when you're
on their plates you would say oh
this is a serial time offender oh wait a
second he's a sex offender
he's assaulted police officers when the
officers were already responding because
he brandished a
gun and now he's reaching into the car
but they didn't shoot him for the priors
they shot him because he was reaching
him
well they shot him because he was
reaching into the car but you do have to
take into account right someone's
criminal violence history
firearms at that point if they knew that
absolutely true right but
it in like just like you said wait he's
doing something worthy of getting shot
the officers
and by the way when your friends are
telling you the same thing the officers
are like stop stop no no no no no like
that you could hear in the background of
the video
take it take a hint i think maybe
everybody's for you stopping walking
right i think if you listen closely you
can hear someone go
here we go again right keep walking you
can do it he's pulling that [ __ ] again
right really like honestly this is not a
new thing for this guy
now is it okay is it sad of course it's
sad when someone loses their life
especially in front of their children
it's more sad for those children that
that man made horrible decisions
including putting the the officers in a
situation where they believed their life
was in jeopardy but you know what
this story is not nearly as sad as a
story uh that would read
officers don't go home to their children
right i'm sorry it's not as
sad i know that people will say oh it's
just no it's not that one life matters
more than the other
it's that you have made decisions and
taken actions that lead you closer to
forfeiting your right to live
the closer you get to the line of
forcing somebody else to protect
their life whether you mean to take it
from them or not
you are no longer in the right there is
there is a scale there and you have to
go all right hold on a second
sex offender okay you have a history of
violence okay you're not complying
okay you're reaching into a car okay
they can't even
what are they supposed to do at this
point they're supposed to wait until you
turn around and shoot one of the
officers dead and then pull their guns
in their life i tell you what i don't
think i know what the protesters in
kenosha are supposed to do also i don't
know if it made all the way up to
sheboygan very big in sheboygan the
writings oh wow sheboygan the writing
the looting very big all over the place
yeah
poker twist up that along with the twist
and yamaguchi
and rioting and burning this is what
they did of course
they knocked an officer unconscious with
a brick could have killed him
easily what happened oh he just got
bricked
he just got bricked they're clapping
they're clapping
the church the fire the fire's kissing
it and i
uh in minneapolis when we were there now
are we supposed to say oh well why why
did you shoot him he only had a brick
right exactly that's not a deadly weapon
that's not a deadly weapon
a brick a knife a black jack and a taser
i mean what point do they have to have a
gun for an officer to use his gun
and we'll get to that in a second
because the next guy who we're about to
talk about actually
did have a knife and that guy said brick
like it was a verb that he was used to
like yo you just got brick like it's
like yeah yeah yeah
correct usual thing like it's an mtv
become a thing yeah
right next to bully beat down only in 25
getting bricked
oh yeah
oh my gosh well one thing about this guy
he is
in serious condition he didn't die from
the shooting uh going back to
i read i read that he had died okay so
the last report that i heard unless
something came out very early this
morning uh he was in serious condition
in the hospital was not dead but
that could have changed i mean you're
too busy i was reading as well
okay and watching that they're pretty
quick and they marked it off
put them in the ambulance took him to
the hospital so they careful
because he reached into a car and
actively looked like he was reaching for
something like
yeah don't do stupidity i don't know
what was he reaching for honestly
what could he possibly have been doing
it doesn't matter but it does
what could he there is in other words
you are trying to rationalize decisions
right as a police officer and you're
taught to do that to de-escalate you're
taught
maybe someone is doing this where you're
supposed to give the benefit of that
versus where you have to take
uh take control of protecting your own
life right at that point and i'll watch
the back of other officers
yeah i cannot think of a scenario where
a guy is resisting
you're pulling at his tank top and reach
that's not a guy who's reaching in for
his insurance he's not a guy who's
reaching in for a temporary license
that's not a guy who's reaching in
to take it out of neutral that is a guy
with a purpose
who is lunging into a car and even maybe
he was maybe like george floyd he was on
drugs and out of his mind that could
lead to a cardiac arrest we have
absolutely no idea
but if you are an officer you ha at that
point can anyone think of a scenario
where you go
oh this is totally normal behavior i'm
not in danger at all i can't
no no absolutely if you can't use force
here in any way like you just can't use
force at all we've talked about this a
number of times but every time that you
do something like this like you ruin an
officer's life who didn't do anything
wrong the governor doesn't come out and
support you what does what does that do
again to the morale of officers what
does it do the next time that they pull
if they hesitate
the next time they could die yeah that's
that's the line they want
to die i get to do whatever i want
because the police can't do anything to
me i'm just going to do whatever it is
is uh being shot while black and not
wanting to be arrested
yes exactly that's what it is that's the
line it's because i didn't want to get
arrested i didn't want to get arrested
no but they had put their life on the
line because you don't want to get this
is another scenario where there's a
warrant out for his arrest
that's one commonality that you see here
right that people always
that's why i said uh before georgia was
about rachard brooks some of them all
kind of bleed together i said i bet you
that this guy had a rap sheet
we said it on air i said i don't have
any evidence right now i bet you there's
a rap sheet there that he was going to
go away for a long time
because that's where you see scenarios
that people violently resist officers
and by the way it happens
all the time if someone has a rap sheet
they do not want to go back to the clink
they're not going to willingly get into
the back of the paddy wagon that's where
all of a sudden claustrophobia appears
right and uh it happens all it happens
all the time that's when people are at
the most dangerous because they have
nothing to lose they're desperate right
and officers know that they know when
they're approaching a suspect that
has that potential like okay this is the
third strike or the fourth time they're
getting arrested for this they're going
away for a while i have to be careful
because they know that yeah they
know that they have to put if you watch
that video the cops are obviously having
to weigh the consequences of their
actions the person who's not weighing
the consequences of their actions and is
acting wildly violently is the guy who
ended up getting shot yeah yeah yeah
so you can paint this as if the cops are
just again just swinging their guns
around doing whatever they want but
really that's the other guy
the guy who got shot is the guy who's
not thinking exactly and the headline
that pissed me off
on twitter it said a black man shot in
the back by police officers i'm like oh
my gosh what happened and i clicked on
it right and then i see on cnn
the lower third as they show the video
the video is right there yeah and
they're showing
black men shot by police officers no
context whatsoever shot in the back
that's something to do right someone
turns their back just like it's like
like it's all the all the options
you can't shoot me you can't see me
wrestling when they go belly down
to avoid a pin that's not how it works
you still have a knife
it's like see i didn't see it it's right
there on your screen can't you say it
looks like he's reaching into the car
can't you provide
some commentary this says casino can you
speak the truth
it burns like i can't
i can't all right here's another one uh
in other uh completely justifiable
officer shootings perpetrators uh this
happened i believe in louisiana oh yeah
uh this is another one i don't know that
you've seen this this happened over the
course of the weekend i saw it on tmz
and again the story was
man shot in the back by officers 10
times
uh i've read both 11 and 10 times maybe
someone can tell me which one is correct
it depends on which side you go to
uh again graphic warning but this is
important because i was
sure that this wouldn't have legs well
this is going to be this is the
clear clear-cut justifiable one uh
uh and uh and here we are
hold on wait we gotta witness this
[Music]
they've already tased him from what i
understand or they tried to tase him
they're trying to block him from getting
in the convenience store that's where
he's going this entire time
he's got a knife the officers are trying
to block him with the car now they're
telling me on the ground they try to
tase him
he's not doing he's continuing to walk
to the convenience store trying to go in
with a knife
as soon as he starts to yeah try to get
in there
so do you hate everyone in that
convenience store right
right what do you think again what is
happening what could be any justifiable
scenario in that case
where you're refusing to comply you
refuse to get down on the ground
tasers aren't working and you're walking
with a knife like it's a part of your
daily checklist like i am with trader
joe's and getting two canned oats this
is the last resort the last resort was
to take him down
he could have gotten there stabbed the
clerk he was clearly going there with a
purpose
that was a man on a mission and you
cannot at that point
other people's lives are in danger and
what again what are you
does does the man have to have a gun
does a man have to have a gun does a man
have to be currently skewering the
clerk's face but
through the bulletproof glass right with
a little little microphone hole which
sort of defeats the purpose
it really does prove glass i knew that
when i said one time i'm like by the way
you can clean up the cockroaches also
bulletproof glass kind of pointless when
there's a hole the size of your
giant right where your head is mouth
does they have to be stabbing somebody
in the face
how are they especially with a knife how
are officers supposed to subdue them at
that point yeah this is one of those
you can't because you're going to get
stabbed and if you yeah if you believe
the entire black lives matter narrative
is this your martyr this guy
this guy who's running at a convenience
store with a knife that's that's the guy
you answer is yes
you know what the officers didn't do
they didn't shoot him for about 150 feet
walking behind him telling him to get on
the ground
the minute that he started to put
somebody else's life in danger because
as soon as he gets in that store
and he has a knife to the throat of the
clerk it's a hostage situation you're
done
somebody could not get to go home
because they went to work that day
and you know what this guy i have no
idea if that clerk pardoned me i have no
idea whoa fatherhood
no i know luke i'm sorry
some of that sexual frustration
[Laughter]
i don't know if the ark i don't know if
that was in a white community or black
community right no idea
it doesn't matter the people in that
store should
not have their life put in jeopardy
because you don't like a man with a
knife being shot by the police
we've moved the goalposts from unarmed
black men and by the way i saw this on
cnn both cnn and young turks but i
repeat myself
so i saw them say uh they were refuting
something tucker carlson said where he
said uh last year it was eight unarmed
black men which was a different step
because i think we've used the stat nine
but yeah i believe it's nine he said
eight unarmed black men were shot by
police officers and they went back to
cnn young turks said except that's not
true and they listed some number of 100
something
no he didn't say black men shot by
officers he said unarmed black men
because that was the standard that you
used by the way many of those unarmed
black men were still committing acts of
violence you can still be punching
someone in the face
if you're unarmed so he went from
unarmed to well
now a knife is not enough aiming a taser
at an officer's face
is not enough right it is this man was
armed this man was armed you were going
to protest a man who was armed and who
was not by the way just assaulting
officers
he was going to likely commit a violent
assault
against one of you yeah yeah he was
sentenced to civilians yeah his knife
was just for the the hot dog sometimes
those things
you know you can't get him out of your
hand
i'm gonna go get some taquitos i need
with my buoy knife
you can't cut through those things with
any other naked give me something i
cannot get my taquitos
cut symmetrically unless i got this
rainbow three [ __ ] right is this ain't
cute
no we don't oh my gosh by the way you're
i said q2 you're famous at qt's i went
into one and they're like you're that
guy and he's like
stephen i love you we love you too he
talks about it he talks about cute
i love qut and it's sad that everybody's
uh you haven't signed up for sponsorship
there qt yeah come on come on i don't
know what
to do get off the sidelines it would be
a shame if all of a sudden i became a
fan of racetrack
no i can't that won't happen don't worry
you downgrade yourself i am at your
mercy
okay i have no leverage because the
racetrack sucks in 7-eleven their
bathrooms are like an episode of lock-up
that's true locked up abroad there we go
oh i forgot do we have that clip by the
way in case you're wondering
what could happen to an officer uh if
they don't take measures to protect
their lives or lives of civilians i
believe that we have a montage here
of the officers who uh what happens if
someone does reach for a glove
reaching their glove box uh or someone
does go into a car let alone a knife but
this last one i almost feel like
should just be discarded unfortunately
there are going to be protests but it's
very very common
that officers have to make split
decisions and when they make the wrong
one and they don't shoot
this can happen
what's up man
[Applause]
that's how fast battle clerk sucks too
battle creek michigan horrible place yes
here we go guy gets to his car
right now they don't shoot him yeah
reaching in
boom boom boom boom starts pulling the
gun starts pulling the trigger on the
officers
and one thing too that's important
people say well there's a discrepancy
there's a discrepancy of force they have
gun those people
don't okay but there also is a
discrepancy right there's a huge chasm
in someone who is
uh hired to enforce the law someone who
is acquiescent someone who's beholden to
the laws and someone who is proactively
breaking the law
that also is an advantage if this cop
says well i can't just murder in cold
blood the other guy says oh
i think i got a leg up because i can
murder in cold red i will well and the
the political climate right now with
police officers is that you can do
whatever you want and police officers
shouldn't be able to do anything back
that just emboldens people right you're
telling everybody
all the police officers are bad people
they're horrible right now we should
defund them you don't have to listen to
them you can do whatever you want and
then somebody goes off and does this and
they're like what did you shoot him for
right because you said this you've
created this environment where every cop
is bad looking to kill a black person
that's not the case they're trying to
avoid that last night by the way we're
two cops
all of the black cops under the rug all
minority officers who make up a high
percentage of police officers in the
general population
they're all uncle toms and self-loathing
you don't want to know anything about
this
look a man with only a knife you know
that last guy too they're pissed off
about the number of times the police
shot this guy they shot him multiple
times
the last guy that shot those two
officers had a bullet in his head and
drove himself to the hospital
yeah okay that's why they shoot like the
world is not enough
you shoot until the perpetrator is down
you don't stop that was until they came
from where the bullet kept going deeper
in his head and it only made him
stronger
mr bond we can't have that we can't have
super soldiers fighting our officers
watch the world is not enough
okay that's why you shoot first
by the way hit the notification bell if
you're subscribed on youtube because
uh subscriptions don't mean a whole lot
uh notifications will make sure that
it's pumped to your uh your mobile
and oh you have ice in your car excuse
me i'm sorry for some reason i hear that
it sounds very whiskey
it does whiskey uh and uh we do this
show uh every weekday
uh monday through thursday at 10 a.m
eastern and let us know if you want us
to uh stream the convention the
republican convention on thursday i
thought it would be boring maybe but
uh maybe we can we'll put a poll out on
twitter and you can let me know maybe
something else i don't under this is
something that i guess maybe someone can
explain it to me wait you're smart
boy let's come in here put him on a
cotton wade i figure
you're exhausted from all your fathering
it's true
he has more experience he's been a
father multiple times uh
it's a given that's true yeah yeah but i
mean you're just like a big
kid i mean you sleep on the yogi bow
that i gave you it's so
[Laughter]
uh in my garage which you know it's just
a jujitsu gym yeah double up the foam
and i was like
that's nice and i woke up with joe
lewis's face and my face cause he wants
to be so close to me he wants to inhale
my breath and then wear my flesh like a
skin like a coat
he's trying to stand around yeah he's a
good dog he's getting he's getting his
because of corolla deville he's
reversing the tables
so about to understand this when this
became a rule that
you can only use what it is that the
perpetrator uses if you are home
alone at night and a rapist comes in and
he only has a knife are you unjustified
in shooting that rapist or should you
only use a knife should you have it i
think it should be as
unfair of a fight as humanly possible
and especially with officers because we
send them out not only to defend their
own lives but to defend our lives that
is actually the contract that we have
with officers
they are paid through our tax dollars
their sworn duty to protect
our rights and this is something that's
a fundamental misunderstanding of police
officers and people who understand this
is yeah i do have a problem with the
militarization of police i do have a
problem with police who are infringing
on our rights if a police officer pulls
me over and asks to search my car for no
reason i say
i would say no no you can't because i do
believe in constitutionally limited
parameters
for officers but understanding the
spirit of the law
they are sworn to protect our rights so
when someone else becomes a threat
to our lives and by the way by proxy
they're a threat to our lives if they
start picking off
officers like dallas and detroit or the
900
officer casualties that we've seen as a
result of these riots
they have at that point i think they
should pull out artillery like their gym
carry in the mask
okay i don't understand when we started
this they have
it's rock paper scissors yeah exactly
you don't exactly yell out all right
what do you have guys he's only got a
knife all right everybody put your guns
down
let's get the knives out guns don't get
your knives out yeah it's like what yeah
well these people are
the cops are living in complicated scary
situations and people on the outside
don't want to deal with the actual
details the details get messy the
details get crazy
and they have to make decisions that we
don't ever have to make or that we don't
typically have to make
and so yeah again from the outside
people on cnn they sit in there they sit
in their studios and they can comment
but they don't actually
want to deal with situations police
officers
yeah and by the way how many well not
really all that well when they uh
ravaged it
that's true yeah they all left it yeah
that was fun because there was a police
precinct down there like just take the
cops just leave her alone
if you cut them open it's just snack
packs he's our special little boy she's
our special little boy shelter
really just if anything happens his
wealthy family is going to get mad
because you know he has no business
hosting a show come on look at him and
this is new and improved skelter
this is post queer eye stealther running
image search for young stelter it's a
stuff that gives children
nightmares and you know what first off
how many of these people are paying
taxes by the way
who don't maybe they don't understand
the contract they have police officers
because they don't pay taxes i have no
idea uh but something else that is
important this could be a teachable
moment with kids you know for example i
knew a kid whose dad died uh
was drinking and driving and the the
conversation they had with their kids
was you know what dad made a mistake
and make sure you don't ever make that
kind of mistake because this could
happen to you yeah but these are not the
conversations that are being had with
these kids right now how do i know
because they're not having these
conversations
at the dnc no mention by the way of the
riots
none at the dnc also no mention of
impeachment not once
zero i also don't think there was any
mention of russia but i could be wrong
it'll come back if you if any surprise
story yeah for three years or kavanaugh
no mention of kavanaugh
but no one is talking about with these
children hey you know what
your dad reached into a car when he was
told to get on your dad took a knife
wielded it and tried to go stab
someone at a convenience store who owed
him some money for a carburetor
don't repeat his mistakes don't do it
instead it's they're out to get you yeah
they're out to get you every time you
get pulled over your life is in danger
statistically it's not true
and even anecdotally now these anecdotes
this is the thing if they're if there
were an example if it were if if it's
out there please send it of a man going
officer
my hands are at ten and two could i have
a license here even i'm a concealed
carry permit holder let me reach for
this in my glove
if there is a video in the last year
with with all of these going up these
black lives matter
antifa riots if you can find a video of
a man saying okay
i'm complying i'm getting on the ground
officer this is this is a
miscommunication
and getting shot getting lit up like the
fourth of july i will stand corrected
i haven't seen it at the very least you
go
okay i can see this is a muddy scenario
i don't
but in all the cases we've presented
this this morning it's entirely
justifiable
yeah absolutely go home have dinner and
don't even skip a meal
yeah break your intermittent fast and go
home and kiss your family because you
get to live another day officers i blame
you
for nothing not something not a little
bit
not two wrongs don't make a right you
did your job thank you officers no
problem here
and they should get a lot of support
from the police unions they should get a
lot of support from the mayor
everybody should be supporting them
right now and saying look we're standing
behind our police officers because you
have to if you don't
police officers are going to quit or
they're going to die on the job that
those are the two things that are going
to happen because people are going to
get shot
themselves i know well and we live in a
very imperfect system i don't know when
we thought that this was perfect that
there was never going to be a mistake
made by police officers that there was
never going to be a perpetrator that
posed a threat that was going to have to
be put down
for some reason it's sad that it happens
but i'd rather they be shot than the
police officer be shot
it's an imperfect system if you do what
cops tell you to do
you will 99.999999999999999999
of the time go home
our ombudsman with gerald's fathering
bullcrap did we hire a math agent yet
listen
all i'm saying is your attention is
split your attention
is split you couldn't possibly know that
number because you have a human to raise
a baby brain man a little human yeah but
if
if you listen to and if you believe the
cnn version of this the online version
the twitter version of this
you are being turned into a stupid
person yeah you are you are they are
not already dumbing it down for you
because they think you're stupid and if
you're
taking it in and again taking the
simplified version of this you are
stupid
yeah wow i just called everyone stupid
you yeah think if you turn your back to
an officer that it's like oh game off
right yeah it's not an invisible cloak
he can still see you i'm under arrest
i'm sorry i'm sorry that i'm a sex
offender and committed child abuse but
ah
all you're gonna do is force him to go
carol in on your sorry ass and
suplex you into oblivion you dumbass
kind of like you're just exposing
yourself more you [ __ ]
okay uh speaking of morons uh
people who wanted to cover this the uh
that wanted to cover it as though the
proud boys descended upon portland
committed mass
acts of violence this is trending right
now it was trending yesterday yeah
and i want to be clear i am not a member
of the proud boys i do not endorse a pro
i just
i'm not a member of any group gang
because eventually you're going to have
someone in there who's an unsavory
character
even though there are blacks and latinos
and proud boys i wouldn't be surprised
if you searched high and low if you find
somebody who probably has some pepe
posts
i don't know maybe somewhere down the
line had a couple of posts at stormfront
no idea but it's clearly not the mission
of the proud boys
as an organization so i want to be clear
i'm not one of them but
this coverage was absolutely ridiculous
100 proud boys showed up in portland
they were violently attacked of course
by antiphon black lives matter
protesters
and then the media tried to point out
the double standard why why aren't they
cracking down to these people they crack
down on peaceful protesters with tear
gas
and the proud boys can show up with nazi
flag well no that's actually not what
happened but here's a clip
there's a nazi flag right there
i'm entertained
and actually there's an umbrella
that's also why i don't want association
with any of those because none of them
can fight
no yeah there's a lot sorry i get
they want to go out there and defend
speakers sometimes from antifa but the
fighting is just absolutely pathetic and
it has to be pathetic because you're
fighting in gangs
and only [ __ ] join gangs folks so
that's a proven thing one guy what a guy
is hitting with an umbrella
what are you trying to annoy people i
mean an umbrella's not going to hurt
anybody
we have that article actually i think we
can bring it up from axios that was
talking about the the convention that
started today
and it said this is trump landia and
they said i see a lot of american flags
in other words the left has admitted
that patriotism is a republican value
yeah it's a conservative trumpian
look at all these american flags but i
remember not too long ago when
your folks the democrat still wore
american flag pins oh because that's
just man way back in this country yeah
he didn't you know have candidates in
the primaries who honeymooned in the
ussr you had people who maybe believed
in a slightly more progressive tax but
they generally still like this country
now you have communist jackas and joe
biden
yeah well and math i think the the math
one yeah yeah particularly funny the gop
will be a trumpian production and in
there they have a direct quote where
they say oh i saw some american flags
trump blandia scary good axios
uh so of course people were furious the
cops didn't intervene immediately and
they were labeling all of the proud boys
uh far right activists okay oh of course
they are now let's accept this premise
for a second this is what i wanted to do
let's and i don't think that the proud
boys are far-right activists uh again
maybe you might have some in there who
are but that's not the mission statement
of the organization
uh far-right activists let's assume that
and of course when people say these
folks exist on the fringes
uh of course we would have to save it as
say antifa and i guess now black lives
matter exists
on the fringes that's right these are
just the extreme leftists so extreme
right
my right your left proud boys uh should
i go stage left stage right i've done
theaters i know some of the theater
terms
uh so i'm culture my right your left
right i'll go
downstage that's down towards you
that's the audience upstage uh you know
what i don't want i don't wanna probably
be upstaged upstage proud boys downstage
black lives matter and antifa
so proud boys they're far right let's
accept this uh from what i saw
they committed zero in property damage
zero and property damage when i saw them
go down yeah yeah
compare that to 700 plus million dollars
in property damage from black lives
matter fires every night
windows for heat from what i saw and
anyone could correct me if i'm wrong out
there you comment let me know because if
i'm wrong i want you to tell me
just be like my wife
[Laughter]
i it's it's never ending a full-time job
yeah i by the way i'll tell you what
you know what i did yesterday what's
that something i got really petty my
wife was like she put her rollerboard
from her gbs like
the wooden board with a roller ball
underneath it to get her balancing yeah
for the third time she put it around the
corner and it's the same color as our
wooden floorboards
and i stepped on it and i hurt my back
and i went and i said can you fall
okay i said we've talked about this
three times next time if you put that
there and i hurt myself i'm going to
yell she's like you why do you always
have to yeah i'm like i'm not yelling i
said i'm going to yell
i'm telling you and then she goes i
actually said okay fine if we're gonna
have a complete this is the role now
we're gonna have a complete and total
lack of consideration for one another
fine
i went and i started smoking a cigar and
i swear to god ashed it on the carpet
oh that's that is that then she walked
in to apologize
saw the ashes walked out and i
immediately knew i was wrong
by the way i love it i would have won
she was doing the right thing
being a childish [ __ ] and by the way
i love what you did you were gonna have
to buy new carpet if that ruined it no
you know what i did i picked a cigar
that i know drops off in chunks
so afterwards it didn't actually get in
the carpet and it's a rug that has like
i'm not sure i trust you on cigar
actually it's the same oh yeah you don't
trust my cigar no by the way no no don't
show it
for sure yeah that shows up for sure
that's absolutely disgusting i was
sitting and again hurt my back
anti-gravity chair and uh
the ash and i went unfortunately i
couldn't get it out because my
inverted sternum was like i pulled up
i'm going to zoom in is it can you oh
boy let me get this oh
[Applause]
[Music]
uh i don't even your comments are
correcting me so much as uh
comments for a nice south yeah yeah
maybe just use common sense next time
so we'll go back to proud boys let's
assume that they are far right zero
property damage compared to blood cells
matter
uh from what i saw zero civilians
targeted or harmed
from what i saw well look at that
certainly no targeting that's not why
they went there they weren't there for a
back the blue rally as far as i
understand
so we have 700 million in property
damage we have no
civilians targeted right here from the
problems again these are this is the
worst the far right has to offer yes
right these guys you can't put in
richard spencer in there because he just
voted for biden
and i always have to remember who
richard spencer is i'm like oh he's the
one white supremacist who still exists
oh okay and he supports joe biden the
bad haircut
yeah but surely they like empty to cvs
or something right maybe
you would assume so i would assume so or
at the very least like a dwayne reed
it is they don't like them out there in
portugal that's a new york thing so you
know what get your facts right before
you come on my show
uh let's contrast this not attacking any
civilians
with black lives matter
well there's one people yeah again i
warn you graphic content here today
because i think you guys need to know
the truth
the goal of that guy trying to drive on
the road
they caught this guy by the way yes yeah
they did go to jail for a very long time
yep or what they should do
is like apocalypto give him the right to
only instead of the right to run he has
the right to reach into a glove box
they knocked this guy out and called him
a loser yeah they claimed he was trying
to run people over it's like that's not
what happens
this is the guy in dallas so we had to
go to the livestream
[Applause]
now as you can see those aren't that's
not warring gangs or factions there no
those are civilians who are around right
again proud boys gotten to fight they
should have gotten the fights they
showed up to fight with antifa and black
lives matter they showed up to back the
blue but listen they
expect it obviously expensive because
really you don't you don't even need to
bait the hook you just show up yeah
exactly it's just around now you just
it's like what do i need to do to
to be the target of their ir for them to
be violent uh
exist walk down the street just exist
human and they will violently attack you
yeah exactly and by the way just because
black lives matter antivir happened to
be
protesting somewhere it doesn't mean
that somebody else can't protest as well
if you're backing their right to protest
you have to back everybody's right
right they can walk down the street and
not do anything wrong it's fine so my
point is this yeah i know we have our
guests we'll be on here within just a
second uh jeremy from
jeremy hamley from the quartering but if
the proud boys
are the far my right your left far right
and black lives matter antifa
are the left and we see no civilians
targeted no police officers targeted
no uh contrast that of course with 900
uh casualties you see people get mad at
me
through casualties because that's the
risk because look up the definition of
casualties
do you pay taxes so casualties from
black lives matter
uh really the only people if you're
checking your closet for the the far
right boogie man the only people need to
be checking their closet checking under
the bed are antifa and black lives
matter yeah so if you out there are
concerned
about which side is more dangerous
there's one side that systematically and
continually there has been a
long-standing history of them being
dangerous to anyone who gets in their
path
versus a it's a cluster bomb versus a
laser guided missile yeah
proud sure it's wrong you can't you
can't just show up and start beating
people up the reason the officers didn't
interfere is because a lot of states
have mutual combat laws i don't know if
that's the case in oregon i don't think
it is i know in washington there is but
if people are mutually engaging in
combat
and it's not going to the point of death
or something incredibly dangerous people
have
that right so when people say why are
the authors doing this because they're
white some of the proud boys are black
no it's because they are not targeting
the officers burning down their
precincts
chanting defund the police and attacking
civilians so if you want to
check your closet under your bed for
far-right activists
you're not going to find the proud boys
there you're going to find not only
antifa
but all of black lives matter okay we're
going to go to a quick break we will be
back with the quartering jeremy hamley
right for this talk leafy being banned
[Music]
open your mind let us begin our quest
to find it for black rifle coffee
company
the colombian sun is not just a fair
weather friend
all year round the sun keeps the
mountain air
as mild as spring for the coffee trees
of van wilders it is the best climate in
the world
supplying only the best coffee beans
from the farm of diligent
fun world is to your door black rifle
coffee
freshly roast each batch to order
the best way to enjoy black rifled
coffee is through the coffee club
chosen coffee is roasted packaged
and shipped free to your door all you
need to do
is go to blackravelcoffee.comcrowder
[Music]
[Music]
and order today eva black rifle coffee
[Music]
do you exclusively shop in dumpsters
you do don't you
[Music]
you look like a homeless man's ass rag a
look only a raccoon
would love is this what a stroke is pure
unadulterated disappointment personified
in clothing
but lucky for you i have a solution
ladderwithcrowdershop.com
now that's what i'm talking about you'll
be beating the women away with a stick
looking that good
beguile your potential mates with your
sheer masculinity
become the envy of all your friends
while showing off
those legs heck you're downright rugged
unfortunately for you it doesn't correct
crippling
anxiety cover your bits and tackle with
silky smooth
ranger panties at lotterycrowdershop.com
all right very glad to have our next
question of course that is
blackriflecoffee.com you get 20
off if you enter in the promo code
crowder i love their coffee very much so
we had something we were there someone
didn't clean the coffee machine here
and uh now you know well you know it's
not me i don't drink it tastes like
listeria
it tastes can't blame me listeria so uh
really glad to have her not black rifle
coffee no not
crap coffee the unclean coffee machine
the sully
uh our next guest jeremy hamley you know
him on the uh youtube as
the quartering you can follow him on the
twitter at the quartering jeremy thank
you for being here sir
uh it's an honor real glad to be here
fan of the show uh glad to be on
well don't let's let's curb our
expectations here okay
um and you spoken actually half asian
lawyer bill richmond if i'm not mistaken
yeah you know uh we've actually i've
engaged with him
and um he told me he was giving me the
crowder price
i thought that was a good thing but uh
now i'm i'm curious how good it was for
me
yeah no that's the i'm annoyed every
time you call price that's the i have to
have a caller id
super screener price um for people who
don't you did a video on this i know
quite a few people have but you kind of
cover these topics
quite a bit so i wanted to have you on
leafy is someone who was really big on
youtube
uh a while back and uh as far as as i
understand it he
is still banned on youtube correct
explain to people what the conflict is
here
yeah he is still banned and as a minor
update his second channel was banned
so the generally
accepted reasoning is that he had made a
series of videos
about a particular content creator
and um some of them were kind of just
click baiting her some of them were
critiquing her directly all as he
describes himself
in comedy and satire apparently
uh youtube didn't like that and so they
banned his channel at the time he had
zero strikes
to date he has received zero
communications from youtube he received
zero emails why his account was banned
team youtube has
replied to thousands of other
requests for uh information on their
official twitter account
and they've ignored his request which
has something like 70 000 interactions
and to be clear leafy is not a small
leafy had like four plus million
subscribers uh yeah and
did it also did gaming if not i'm not
super familiar i know i had the emo cut
that's about what i remember
yeah no chad people say yeah yeah as
well as some sort of a weak chin
but i i don't like leafy's content
wasn't exactly for me
but my interest in it is simply the
naked exposure of youtube's community
guideline strikes
meaning nothing yeah he had
in my opinion strikes should be
things that issued our issues to give
corrective action
right if if you're going to issue all
three at once
yeah and you basically just have a
public execution
what what is the point for other content
creators to rely on the system
right yeah what's the point to a warning
if it's like hey i fired a warning shot
and he's dead well he fired a warning
shot and then nine times straight to the
sternum
well it seems like the warning shot was
kind of incidental at that point charles
um yeah let me ask what's the general
reaction from uh again for people who
don't know this wasn't political this is
just it's it's not consistent
with youtube's guidelines and by the way
i'm sorry that those guidelines have
gotten more stringent
guilty apologies i didn't
intend for it to be the case but in my
case right we had criticized vox many
times and not just uh specific people at
vox would criticize multiple different
people
multiple different channels from vox or
different series on their channel
and obviously some individuals got upset
and youtube acknowledged that this was
by and large it was a criticism of vox's
ideas and yeah listen ad hominem
sometimes because it's funny i mean you
just said weak chin and i see this as a
man who grew a beard to hide my own very
weak chin um
and if i drool it goes straight down
into my chest ashburn
so but here's my question is the the
issue is obviously inconsistent
application of guidelines and there's no
real use to them if they
if they aren't something that people
understand what i find really upsetting
is when you get big youtubers uh and i i
i don't want to throw you under the bus
but people like h3h3 before you know
philip defranco people who are these big
youtubers out there who go
well i'm either happy about this or what
do you guys think and they don't take a
stand right you see that all the time
like i don't know what are you doing
yeah what do you what do you beautiful
bastards think i don't know do you have
an opinion because they're coming for
you next what do you think what is the
reaction been from
from youtube and people online in
general is it been largely positive
because i know this person
was disliked or do these people also
understand that even if they dislike
somebody
uh it still doesn't set a good precedent
for this person to be permabanned
well to be you know so just first and
foremost i think you already know or
some of your viewers we do share them my
opinion is that it's 100
grade a bs uh
and whether or not you like this content
is irrelevant
to me i think that most people in the
know
have had this kind of a take some of his
content is difficult to defend
there were definitely terms of service
breaking things in some of his videos
and i've covered that
and he's definitely deserved a strike or
two
for some of that stuff but what's
really disgusting is some of these large
creators uh like you've mentioned
and i'll go a step further because i'm
on your platform and i won't suffer as
much as you
uh a creator like h3h3
openly celebrating it yeah right that is
this stuff that i
cannot stand it is one of the most
you know there's that saying right they
came for whatever and then i said
nothing and i said nothing and then when
they came for me there was no one left
right
it's there's another youtuber who was
subject of
a serious amount of cancer culture and
he put out tweet basically like well
nothing of value was lost now i won't
say that um freedom
leafy yeah i won't say that leafy was
necessarily a victim of cancelled
culture
but it did spin up after he was
terminated
a lot of people jumping on that wow i've
been you know before he lost his
platform i hadn't said anything but
now that he's gone i've been against his
clear harassment for years
yeah i hate him before it was cool yeah
right right yeah
yeah and that's and that's coming from
some of the large creators
and it's difficult because as someone
who supports alt
tech uh and you support as well i see
you have a bit shoot account which is
good for you
uh but the you know these creators don't
see an alternative and they don't see
the big picture
and they don't see that what they'll say
down the road
or an old joke they made will come back
to get them the second people wanted to
and it's such yeah it's such a
hypocritical position to take so i think
the overall position
sorry is that most people understand
it's a bad thing
there are a few people with very
poor takes uh usually people that
he's made fun of quite honestly it's
it's nakedly
it's like a total obvious hypocrisy so
right you know in general i think people
are against
it yeah and i have a real and we're
going to go to a web extended at uh
london's kind of dot com mug club here
really quickly for people who are
watching on youtube because sometimes we
can't discuss everything on youtube
but i'm someone who was the victim of
this myself by the way uh in that the
you know the young turks when i had like
50 000 subscribers the reason go people
say well why do you have such an axle
ground with them why don't anymore
because it would be bullying it would be
like punching down
but when i was coming up they targeted
me when i was a small channel
and i never wanted them to be banned i
just wanted to be able to have a debate
i wanted to be able to
have my content be just as publicly
available as there so i have been the
victim of targeted campaigns both from
people who were bullying when i was
small
and cancel culture and i don't advocate
for any of those people to be banned
we've had people on the show that i
disagree with who've been banned and i
don't advocate for it so someone like an
h3h3 who i saw and obviously i've seen
philip defranco i've seen a few people
in the past just
i'm so disappointed when i see it and
they sort of are are taking up arms with
the nbc
uh you know abc cbs's where they're
trying to protect what's theirs they
have a huge platform now they want to
slam the door behind them
and uh listen that's fine if they want
to say that i just don't want to see his
name is ethan klein you say this is my
opinion i don't want to see him
ever bitching about cancel culture ever
again or complaining when something of
his is taken out of context you've lost
that right
and anyone here in this office hold on
we're going to continue talking uh
behind the paywall at mug club uh but
for
right now people watching go to the
quartering on youtube uh
and youtube you can piss off